there's this harris woman uh kamala
harris and we played some video of her
last week this was the most inauthentic
woman on the face of the planet again
she was polling at zero
that's not white power this is joe biden
when when democrats do this it means
zero when republicans do it it means
white power so i'm doing it you can take
it as you wish uh last week she had us
they had a surprise birthday party for
her she walked into the room and yelled
surprise to them first time that's ever
happened in the history of surprise
parties
she then kissed her husband who was also
wearing a mask
i mean this woman is just terrible
pulling at zero in her own party when
when she dropped out of the race but
then biden put her in although it's not
really bite and it's whoever's running
biden anyway
she tweeted out this statement now think
of all the things before i read it to
you before we show it to you think of
all the things that are happening right
now between vaccine mandates inflation
going up gas prices going up supply
chain issues the disaster in afghanistan
that we don't even talk about anymore
china's testing some like supersonic
nuclear missile like there's so many
crazy things happening right now but
here's what vp harris is up to
president biden and i released the first
ever national gender strategy
we believe that advancing gender equity
and equality is fundamental to every
individual's economic security safety
health and ability to exercise their
most basic rights it is also essential
to economic growth and development
democracy and political stability and
the security of nations across the globe
yet no country in the world has achieved
gender equality and we are at an
inflection point the kovit 19 pandemic
has fueled a health crisis an economic
crisis and a caregiving crisis that have
magnified the challenges that women and
girls especially women and girls of
color have long faced it has also
exacerbated a shadow pandemic of
gender-based violence in the united
states and around the world this moment
demands that we build back
better
before i color that with any of my
thoughts we've got a quote here from the
american enterprise institute about
about men and women and equality
women have earned almost 10 million more
college degrees than men since 1982. so
if you only care about women being
educated and having jobs if you think
that's the most important thing for a
woman because i know somehow modern
feminists think that if you're a mother
who has kids and stays at home and cooks
for the kids and keeps a good house and
takes care of everybody and is around
and emotionally available and not
worried about board meetings and things
somehow you're evil and you're
anti-woman
but
if you if you don't believe that then at
least you've got the 10 million more
college degrees than men since uh 1982.
uh but just to add a couple of my
thoughts on this um it's nonsense it's
complete nonsense um there are countries
you know one of the struggles years ago
i've told the story a few times but when
jordan and i jordan peterson and i were
on tour we went to sweden and we were
going to do one show in sweden and the
show sold out literally in two minutes
so we thought there's something going on
here and i was getting so much fan mail
from sweden we thought there's something
else happening here let's see if we can
get back to sweden so i think we went to
denmark for a day maybe we went to oslo
and then we went back to
stockholm to sweden
the second show sold out in in about two
minutes and it was just extraordinary
what was going on there and we talked to
a bunch of the audience we did a q a it
was actually uh during my meet and greet
that instead of doing it at the theater
there were so many people that wanted to
be part of my meet and greet we actually
went to a bar we took over the entire
bar it was it was maybe the best night
of the whole tour
sweden has complete gender equality they
have a completely egalitarian society
and forever men can do whatever they
want women can do whatever they want and
guess what's happened in sweden it's
still despite saying everybody do
whatever the hell you want which is
pretty much what we have here in the
united states too
but they really have it there
in terms of culture and everything else
it turns out that still men wanted to
become engineers and women still wanted
to become nurses because generally men
care about things that's the way men's
brains are wired and women care more
about interpersonal relationships so
that's the way their brains are wired so
now the social justice warriors in
sweden they look at that and they go
wait we have equality but we did it
right like we did what they wanted we
have this egalitarian society we did it
right but the outcome is still that men
and women are doing different things we
don't have the exact amount of male and
female engineers we don't have the exact
amount of male and female nurses so they
want to rejigger the entire system do
you see how ridiculous this all is
anyway the idea that we'd be worried
about that about any of this nonsense if
you showed me a law that said women
can't do this
because they're women then so be it you
know what women can't do uh apparently
women can't be four-star generals
because you know uh what's her name
i forgot her name who's what's her name
again
rachel levine rachel levine yeah rachel
levine so rachel levine was a man i
don't mean to be a dick about it that
was that
so
there was a guy
anyway he's a woman now
he's was he's now the first four-star
female general according to the new york
times except he's not female i i don't
want to get my channel deleted and i'm
not trying to say anything controversial
here he's a trans woman i accept that
she or she's a trans woman but she is
not female
google female here can be google female
can you google female for me right now
and i'm going to read the official
uh definition
of female for those of you that are
completely curious
female
is of or denoting the sex that can bear
offspring or produce eggs distinguished
biologically by the production of ova
which can be fertilized by male gametes
i don't think rachel levine has that
stuff so i'm not making a big deal about
it and it's just fine that this trans
person's got a gig and it's all good uh
except she
he she whatever is not female that's not
i'm not trying to be controversial here
but anyway you see why i link this to
they want gender equity except the
four-star general that's the health
secretary whatever it is is biologically
male and you've got the feminists going
oh my god we've got the first female oh
my god i'm a seal throw me more fish